[Music]
alex is in oklahoma city hi alex how are
you
hey dave hey anthony how are you guys
great how can we help
great um i'm just calling because so my
wife and i just got married just got
back from the honeymoon
congrats well thank you thank you
joining
accounts today um and we are renting
an apartment at the time being um
currently we bring in about 115
and my question result or revolves
around
money market account savings account
brokerage account for a mortgage
so ideally we're looking probably about
two years
could potentially be three i'm wanting
to hit
50 to 60k to ensure 20
down on the house um you know since it's
in that gray area of the two to three
and not the three to five that you
normally say
is brokerage account you know invested
in good mutual funds
is that you know the i the step we
should take or should we just simply
keep it in our savings now or maybe even
go to the money market account
okay we skip straight to buying a house
i does that mean you're a hundred
percent debt
yes i'm sorry yeah and you already have
your emergency fund in place
already have our emergency fund wow um
yeah no we're we got a great head start
for 26.25
you do yeah you're killing it okay now
let me just make sure we're clearing
this too
the 50 60 is not including the
emergency fund correct that's going to
be an extra 50 and 60 definitely extra
extra
uh extra on top of them okay so it's the
same discussion we're having a few
minutes ago
absolutely um you know you've got two to
three years or
one to one to three years rather than
three to five do you take the risk of an
um s p an s p 500 you know mutual fund
or something like that i wouldn't feel
with a brokerage account but
uh never full of brokerage accounts but
um i pretty much dump it into an s p
or a long term invested in mutual funds
uh through my smartvestor pro
but i i think you know the difference is
about a ten percent swing
yeah and so we're talking about four or
five thousand dollars more you're going
to make or lose
if you put this in a if you put this in
a mutual fund
uh versus you're going to make almost
nothing but you're not going to lose
anything right if you stay with the
money market so you guys can just look
at that and say emotionally
what can we do financially you can take
the risk yeah
it's not going to keep you from buying a
house it's not going to cause you to be
able to buy a house
either way right either way so it's just
a matter how you know what you want to
take the risk on if i was a husband i'm
taking a risk
okay there you go this is the dave
ramsey show